- Selamat datang ke Memahami
Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum.
Nama saya John Watrous, dan saya pengarah teknikal
IBM Quantum Education.
Tujuan siri ini adalah untuk bagi korang
pemahaman yang kukuh tentang maklumat dan pengiraan kuantum, dan itu bermakna kita kena masuk
ke dalam butiran teknikal
maklumat kuantum dan tengok macam mana pengiraan kuantum
betul-betul berfungsi, apa yang boleh dan tak boleh dibuat.
Kalau korang belum tengok
video gambaran keseluruhan untuk siri ni, saya galakkan korang tengok dulu.
Dalam video tu, korang akan jumpa maklumat tentang jenis persediaan latar belakang
yang disyorkan untuk siri ni, serta garis besar
topik yang akan diliputi.
Juga, jangan lupa tengok
buku teks Qiskit, yang merangkumi bahan
yang sama dengan siri video ni dalam bentuk bertulis,
dan ia juga termasuk
komponen interaktif dan antara muka kepada perkakasan dan perisian yang direka untuk bantu korang lebih faham
maklumat dan pengiraan kuantum. Korang akan jumpa pautan ke video gambaran keseluruhan dan buku teks Qiskit
dalam deskripsi.
Ini adalah pelajaran satu daripada
unit satu dalam siri ni.
Unit satu merangkumi asas-asas
maklumat kuantum, dan dalam pelajaran pertama unit ni, kita akan fokus pada macam mana
maklumat kuantum berfungsi
untuk sistem tunggal, bermakna kita ada
hanya satu sistem fizikal atau peranti yang menyimpan maklumat kuantum
dan kita tengok macam mana
satu sistem atau peranti tu berfungsi secara berasingan.
Dalam pelajaran selepas ni, kita akan bincang macam mana
maklumat kuantum berfungsi bila ada berbilang sistem dan itu akan membolehkan kita
menerangkan konsep-konsep
menarik dan penting seperti algoritma kuantum yang guna berbilang qubit
dan protokol kuantum
yang melibatkan berbilang individu yang memproses maklumat kuantum dan menghantarnya ke depan dan
belakang antara satu sama lain.
Tapi sebelum masuk ke perbincangan tu, masuk akal untuk bermula dengan
tetapan yang agak mudah iaitu satu sistem secara berasingan,
sebahagiannya sebab elok mulakan dengan yang mudah, tapi juga sebab macam mana yang akan kita tengok, penerangan tentang macam mana
maklumat kuantum berfungsi
untuk sistem tunggal secara berasingan membawa secara semula jadi dan logik kepada penerangan tentang macam mana
untuk berbilang sistem.
Ni gambaran ringkas pelajaran ni.
Kita akan mula dengan membincangkan
maklumat klasik.
Tujuan pelajaran ni bukan untuk terangkan macam mana
maklumat klasik berfungsi, tapi untuk terangkan macam mana
maklumat kuantum berfungsi,
tapi untuk terangkan macam mana
maklumat kuantum berfungsi, sangat membantu untuk mulakan
dengan maklumat klasik dan guna ia sebagai
titik rujukan yang dah biasa
bila kita bincang maklumat kuantum.
Pada tahap matematik, maklumat kuantum dan klasik sebenarnya ada penerangan yang agak serupa dengan beberapa perbezaan utama, tentulah.
Malah, maklumat kuantum
sebenarnya tak terpisah langsung daripada maklumat klasik.
Ia adalah sambungan daripada
maklumat klasik.
Hakikatnya
adalah, sekurang-kurangnya pada pandangan saya, korang betul-betul tak boleh
faham maklumat kuantum kalau korang tak faham
maklumat klasik,
jadi mulakan dengan maklumat klasik
memang masuk akal.
Saya memang jangkakan
kandungan ni akan biasa kepada sesetengah penonton, tapi walaupun korang dah biasa dengannya, saya tak sarankan korang langkau ia.
Selain menekankan aspek-aspek maklumat klasik yang paling relevan untuk
memahami maklumat kuantum, kita akan memperkenalkan
notasi Dirac dalam bahagian ni,
yang merupakan cara standard
yang akan kita guna untuk menerangkan vektor dan
matriks sepanjang siri ni.
Rupanya, notasi Dirac tak
khusus untuk maklumat kuantum.
Ia boleh digunakan sama dalam konteks maklumat klasik mahupun dalam banyak tetapan lain di mana vektor dan matriks timbul.
Kita kemudian akan beralih kepada maklumat kuantum, dan secara khususnya, kita akan
bincang perwakilan keadaan kuantum sebagai vektor,
jenis pengukuran mudah yang dipanggil pengukuran asas standard, dan operasi unitary, yang menerangkan perubahan masa diskret
dalam sistem kuantum.
Sekali lagi, semua dalam tetapan
sistem tunggal.
Sebelum kita mulakan pelajaran ni sendiri, akan membantu untuk jelaskan bahawa sebenarnya ada dua penerangan
tentang maklumat kuantum, penerangan yang dipermudahkan, yang mana yang akan kita
fokuskan dalam pelajaran ni
dan sepanjang unit pertama ni dan penerangan umum, yang diliputi dalam unit kemudian, khususnya dalam
unit ketiga siri ni.
Penerangan yang dipermudahkan,
sesuai dengan namanya, lebih mudah dan ia
biasanya dipelajari dahulu.
Dalam penerangan yang dipermudahkan, macam yang dah saya cadangkan, keadaan kuantum diwakili oleh vektor dan operasi diwakili
oleh matriks unitary.
Penerangan maklumat kuantum
ini mencukupi untuk pemahaman tentang
kebanyakan algoritma kuantum, contohnya,
jadi ia bukan terlalu dipermudahkan, ia adalah perkara sebenar.
Walau bagaimanapun, macam yang kita akan
jumpa sepanjang perjalanan, ia ada beberapa batasan.
Contohnya, kalau kita nak
model kesan bunyi pada sistem kuantum, penerangan ini rupanya tak mencukupi.
WEBVTT
Penerangan umum pula
lebih umum dan akhirnya, ia lebih
berkuasa dari segi matematik.
Dalam penerangan ni, keadaan kuantum diwakili oleh kelas khas matriks
yang dipanggil matriks densiti,
dan kelas pengukuran dan operasi yang lebih umum boleh diterangkan termasuk
bunyi, contohnya.
Ia selaras sepenuhnya dengan
penerangan yang dipermudahkan dan sebenarnya, korang boleh tengok
penerangan yang dipermudahkan
sebagai kes khas
penerangan umum, dan ia juga merangkumi maklumat klasik sebagai kes khas.
Ia juga sangat
cantik dalam cara ia semua berfungsi, jadi saya sangat galakkan korang pelajari tentang penerangan umum ni
bila masanya dah sesuai, tapi penerangan yang dipermudahkan adalah tempat yang lebih semula jadi untuk bermula, dan itulah yang akan kita buat.
Kita akan mulakan dengan bercakap tentang maklumat klasik dengan tumpuan pada aspek-aspek
maklumat klasik yang paling relevan
terhadap maklumat kuantum
dan cara ia diterangkan
secara matematik.
Bayangkan kita ada
sistem fizikal atau peranti yang menyimpan maklumat.
Kita akan bagi sistem ni nama X, tapi nama ni
tak ada apa-apa yang penting.
Kita boleh guna nama lain
kalau nak, tapi sekadar nak pilih nama,
kita akan panggil sistem ni X.
Kita akan buat andaian tentang X, iaitu ada
set terhingga keadaan klasik yang mungkin ada pada X pada bila-bila masa.
Di sini, bila saya sebut keadaan klasik, saya maksudkan konfigurasi sistem yang boleh dikenali dan
diterangkan tanpa sebarang kesamaran
tanpa sebarang ketidakpastian atau ralat.
Sebenarnya, ini adalah sesuatu yang korang boleh fikirkan secara intuitif. Pada tahap matematik, kita hanya define
set keadaan klasik,
kita pilih ia macam mana pun kita nak atau dengan cara yang paling baik
menerangkan peranti yang kita guna.
Bagi nama sigma kepada
set keadaan klasik ni, dan sekali lagi, nak tekankan
bahawa kita anggap sigma adalah set terhingga.
Set keadaan klasik
sistem X ni tak terhingga besarnya macam
set semua nombor asli.
Ia terhingga, dan itulah sahaja
andaian yang kita buat.
Contohnya, mungkin X adalah bit, dalam kes tu, set keadaan klasik adalah set yang mengandungi dua
elemen: sifar dan satu.
Kadang-kadang kita rujuk
set ni sebagai abjad binari.
Contoh lain adalah X
merupakan dadu enam sisi biasa, dalam kes tu, keadaan klasik adalah nombor satu hingga enam.
Sudah tentu, kita bercakap
tentang abstraksi di sini.
Dadu enam sisi sebenar mungkin
ada banyak sifat berbeza seperti kedudukan tepat,
orientasinya,
suhunya, dan sebagainya. Tapi berkaitan maklumat yang paling biasanya relevan bila kita bercakap tentang dadu enam sisi,
keadaan klasik adalah
nombor satu hingga enam yang ditunjukkan oleh bilangan titik pada sisi dadu yang menghadap ke atas.
Kalau X adalah suis pada
kipas elektrik biasa yang mungkin ada kat rumah korang, maka mungkin keadaan klasik
adalah tetapan tinggi,
sederhana, rendah dan mati.
Ini cuma contoh-contoh. Kita boleh bayangkan sistem yang ada set keadaan klasik
berbeza daripada ni, tapi harapannya, ia menyampaikan idea
bahawa konsep keadaan klasik ni adalah sesuatu yang sepatutnya
biasa dan boleh difahami dalam terma yang mudah dan intuitif.
Secara matematik, set keadaan klasik
hanyalah set terhingga, dan sudah tentu, set ini mesti
juga tak kosong.
Mesti ada sekurang-kurangnya
satu keadaan klasik yang boleh ada pada sistem tu dan mesti ada sekurang-kurangnya dua keadaan klasik
kalau sistem tu berguna untuk menyimpan maklumat.
Sekarang, dalam sesetengah situasi, kita mungkin tahu X berada
dalam keadaan tertentu, tapi dalam banyak situasi,
yang timbul dalam tetapan
pemprosesan maklumat, mungkin ada ketidakpastian tentang keadaan klasik sistem
pada saat tertentu
supaya setiap keadaan klasik yang mungkin ada kebarangkalian yang berkaitan dengannya.
Contohnya, kalau X adalah bit, maka mungkin X berada dalam keadaan klasik sifar
dengan kebarangkalian tiga suku empat dan berada dalam keadaan satu
dengan kebarangkalian satu suku empat.
Kita akan rujuk ini
sebagai keadaan kebarangkalian, dan kita boleh nyatakan
keadaan kebarangkalian ni, macam yang korang tengok kat sini,
hanya dengan menunjukkan apa
kebarangkalian untuk keadaan klasik yang berbeza.
Cara yang lebih ringkas untuk nyatakan
keadaan kebarangkalian ni adalah dengan vektor, khususnya perwakilan
yang korang tengok kat sini
adalah vektor lajur, dan vektor ni menunjukkan
apa kebarangkalian untuk dua keadaan klasik yang mungkin.
Lebih khusus lagi, entri pertama menunjukkan
apa kebarangkalian untuk X berada dalam keadaan sifar, dan entri kedua memberitahu
kita apa kebarangkalian
untuk sistem berada dalam keadaan satu. Ini hanyalah cara semula jadi untuk susun abjad binari,
atau sekurang-kurangnya, itulah cara
kita dilatih untuk buat ni. Dengan sifar dahulu dan satu kedua.
Ke depan, kita akan guna
istilah vektor kebarangkalian untuk menunjukkan vektor macam ni.
WEBVTT
Khususnya, ia adalah vektor yang semua entri-entrinya adalah
nombor nyata tak negatif dan di mana hasil tambah
entri-entri adalah sama dengan satu,
jadi masuk akal untuk
fikirkan entri-entri ni sebagai kebarangkalian.
Dalam contoh ni, ada hanya dua entri sebab ada hanya dua
keadaan klasik bagi sistem yang kita bincangkan,
tapi secara umum, boleh ada
bilangan entri yang mana-mana dengan pemahaman
bahawa ada satu entri untuk setiap keadaan klasik
bagi sistem yang kita bincangkan.
Kita akan teruskan
membincangkan maklumat klasik, vektor kebarangkalian dan
sebagainya sebentar lagi, tapi dahulu, ia akan sangat membantu
untuk memperkenalkan beberapa notasi
untuk menerangkan vektor yang dikenali sebagai notasi Dirac.
Sebenarnya, ini hanya bahagian pertama
notasi Dirac.
Ada beberapa
aspek lain notasi Dirac yang akan kita jumpa sedikit
kemudian dalam pelajaran ni.
Notasi ni akan jadi
sangat penting untuk cara kita menerangkan maklumat kuantum, jadi adalah penting untuk
faham macam mana ia berfungsi,
tapi nasib baik, ia sangat mudah dan ia betul-betul tak ada
kaitan khusus dengan maklumat kuantum,
jadi kita boleh perkenalkan ia sekarang
dalam konteks maklumat klasik yang dah biasa.
Macam sebelum ni, kita anggap kita ada set sigma
keadaan klasik bagi sesuatu sistem, dan kita anggap
kita ada susunan
keadaan klasik ni, sama macam kita rujuk susunan abjad binari
dalam contoh sebelum ni. Cara lain untuk kata ni
adalah bahawa elemen-elemen sigma diletakkan dalam hubungan
dengan integer
dari satu hingga berapa banyak pun
elemen yang ada dalam sigma, yang mana notasi kat sini dengan dua bar di sekeliling sigma bermaksud.
Itulah bilangan
elemen dalam set sigma.
Jadi ada keadaan pertama,
keadaan kedua, dan seterusnya.
Susunan atau hubungan
khusus yang kita pilih sebenarnya tak akan penting sangat.
Yang betul-betul penting adalah
kita ada susunan dan kita ikutinya.
Untuk banyak set keadaan klasik
yang akan kita jumpa, akan ada susunan standard sama macam yang kita ada dengan
abjad binari,
dan kalau tak ada susunan standard, kita boleh pilih satu.
Tapi apa pun ia, pemahamannya adalah kita ikutinya.
Sekarang, ni dia notasi
yang diperkenalkan.
Untuk mana-mana pilihan keadaan klasik
a daripada set sigma kita, kita tulis ni kat sini, yang dibaca sebagai ket a
untuk bermakna vektor lajur
yang ada satu dalam entri yang berpadanan dengan a dan sifar untuk semua entri lain.
Contohnya, kalau kita kembali
kepada abjad binari, yang mana, macam yang korang mungkin dah agak, adalah contoh yang sangat penting
yang akan kita kembali lagi dan lagi. Maka ket sifar dan ket satu adalah vektor yang ditakrifkan kat sini.
Ket sifar adalah vektor
yang ada satu dalam entri yang berpadanan dengan keadaan klasik sifar, yang mana adalah entri pertama,
dan sifar untuk semua entri lain, dan dalam kes ni, ada
hanya satu entri lain.
Begitu juga, ket satu adalah
vektor kat sini di mana kita ada satu dalam
entri yang berpadanan dengan satu,
yang mana adalah entri kedua, dan sifar untuk semua entri lain, yang mana, sekali lagi, hanya satu entri.
Ni contoh lain. Dalam contoh ni, kita ada set keadaan klasik sigma yang berpadanan dengan empat suit
dalam set kad main standard: clubs, diamonds, hearts, dan spades.
Dalam kes ni, sebenarnya tak ada
susunan yang dipersetujui secara universal untuk suit-suit ni.
Untuk banyak permainan kad, tak ada susunan langsung. Ia hanya empat suit berbeza dan itulah yang penting, dan ada permainan kad berbeza
yang memang susun suit-suit ni
dengan cara berbeza, tapi ia tak penting sangat.
Kita boleh pilih
susunan macam yang korang tengok kat sini.
Ni kebetulan adalah susunan abjad mengikut nama empat suit ni yang ditulis dalam bahasa Inggeris,
Dengan andaian kita dah pilih
susunan tertentu ni, maka kita takrifkan empat vektor ni: ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts, dan ket spades
macam yang korang tengok kat sini, dan vektor-vektor ni berpadanan
dengan penerangan umum yang korang tengok kat sini.
Memandangkan kita dah pilih
susunan tertentu ni untuk empat suit ni.
Kita boleh buat perkara yang sama untuk mana-mana set keadaan klasik
yang kita pilih.
Ingat bahawa set keadaan klasik sentiasa bermakna set terhingga dan tak kosong.
Vektor dalam bentuk ni
dipanggil vektor asas standard, dan ia adalah fakta asas tentang vektor bahawa setiap vektor boleh
dinyatakan dengan cara unik
sebagai gabungan linear
vektor asas standard.
Contohnya, kembali kepada contoh dari sebentar tadi, vektor kebarangkalian
yang kita nampak boleh dinyatakan
macam yang korang tengok kat sini. Ia pada dasarnya hanya cara alternatif untuk menyatakan vektor
yang akan sangat berguna untuk beberapa sebab ke depan.
WEBVTT
Dan dengan notasi tu sekarang ada dalam tangan kita, jom kembali kepada perbincangan
tentang maklumat klasik dan keadaan kebarangkalian, khususnya.
Dan jom tengok apa yang berlaku
bila kita ukur sistem semasa ia dalam keadaan kebarangkalian.
Kita mungkin tak biasanya
merujuk pengukuran atau tindakan mengukur
sesuatu dalam tetapan klasik, tapi istilah ni masuk akal.
Pada asasnya, bila kita bercakap
tentang mengukur sistem X dalam konteks ni, kita hanya bermaksud kita tengoknya dan kita kenali keadaan apa pun ia.
Sudah tentu, bila kita tengok sistem tu, kita tak nampak keadaan kebarangkalian, kita nampak keadaan klasik,
dan keadaan klasik
yang kita nampak tu adalah satu yang boleh
kita bayangkan dipilih secara rawak mengikut kebarangkalian.
Sekarang, korang mungkin bantah atas
alasan falsafah kepada idea bahawa keadaan klasik yang kita nampak tu entah macam mana dipilih secara rawak
pada saat kita ukur atau kita tengok sistem tu, sistem tu hanya berada dalam keadaan klasik tertentu sepanjang masa
dan kita kebetulan baru
tahu apa keadaannya, tapi demi memikirkan tentang kerangka matematik yang kita guna,
tak apa untuk fikirkan macam ni dan berbuat demikian akan membolehkan kita buat perbandingan dengan
maklumat kuantum sedikit kemudian.
Anggaplah bahawa
keadaan klasik yang kita nampak adalah keadaan klasik a, yang boleh jadi mana-mana keadaan dalam set sigma kita.
Ini mengubah keadaan kebarangkalian
X secara umum, sekurang-kurangnya dari sudut pandang kita.
Kebarangkalian tak lagi
ada sebarang kepentingan sebab kita kini tahu apa
keadaan klasik X.
Ia adalah a, dan tak ada lagi
sebarang ketidakpastian tentang ni.
Jadi kita sekarang akan kata
bahawa kebarangkalian sistem berada dalam keadaan a adalah satu.
Kita tahu ni sebab kita baru tengok dan kita nampak bahawa keadaan klasik adalah a, jadi keadaan kebarangkalian baru X adalah satu
di mana kebarangkalian
berada dalam keadaan klasik a adalah sama dengan satu.
Dan keadaan kebarangkalian tu diwakili oleh
vektor kebarangkalian ket a.
Kita ada satu dalam entri yang berpadanan dengan keadaan klasik a dan sifar dalam semua entri lain.
Contohnya, kalau kita semula
pertimbangkan situasi di mana X adalah bit dan kita ada
keadaan kebarangkalian yang sama macam sebelum ni,
maka kalau kita ukur X, kita boleh bayangkan
peralihan berlaku.
Dengan kebarangkalian tiga suku empat, kita nampak keadaan klasik sifar, dan dengan mengukur, kita beralih ke ket sifar
sebagai keadaan kebarangkalian kita,
dan dengan kebarangkalian satu suku empat, kita beralih ke ket satu.
Korang boleh fikirkan ni sebagai peralihan pengetahuan kalau korang suka berbanding peralihan fizikal
sebenar,
tapi yang penting untuk
tujuan pelajaran ni adalah untuk kenali macam mana matematik berfungsi.
Ia sebenarnya agak remeh, tapi dengan mengenali keremeh-temehan ni, penerangan yang sama untuk tetapan kuantum
mungkin kelihatan sedikit kurang misteri.
Satu nota akhir adalah bahawa bagi orang lain yang tak kebetulan nampak apa
keadaan klasik X masa kita ukurnya,
keadaan kebarangkalian
sudah tentu tak akan berubah akibat kita mengukurnya.
Tak apa. Individu yang berbeza boleh
ada pengetahuan berbeza tentang sistem tertentu dan sewajarnya pilih
keadaan kebarangkalian yang berbeza
untuk mewakili
pengetahuan mereka tentang sistem tu.
Dalam bahagian terakhir perbincangan maklumat klasik ni, kita akan bincang operasi klasik yang boleh dilakukan pada sistem,
mulakan dengan operasi deterministik.
Bila kita lakukan operasi pada sistem, keadaannya biasanya berubah akibatnya, dan dalam konteks ni, perkataan deterministik bermaksud
bahawa hasil melakukan
operasi tu bergantung sepenuhnya pada keadaan klasik
apa pun sistem tu
sebelum operasi dilakukan.
Dengan kata lain, tak ada
unsur kebetulan bila operasi deterministik dilakukan, jadi tak ada rawak
atau ketidakpastian yang terlibat.
Dalam terma matematik, operasi deterministik
diterangkan oleh fungsi.
Setiap fungsi f dalam bentuk
yang korang tengok kat sini, yang bermaksud bahawa kedua-dua input dan output fungsi
berpadanan dengan elemen-elemen
set keadaan klasik sigma kita menerangkan operasi deterministik.
Keadaan klasik a
diubah menjadi keadaan f dari a untuk setiap pilihan keadaan a.
Untuk setiap fungsi f dalam bentuk ni, akan selalu ada matriks unik M yang memenuhi syarat ni yang korang tengok kat sini,
dan itulah dengan mendarab
M kepada vektor ket a memberikan kita vektor ket f dari a,
dan itu betul untuk setiap
pilihan keadaan klasik a.
Tak susah sangat untuk tulis
penerangan eksplisit M dengan fungsi f
dalam bentuk ni yang kita pilih.
Ia akan selalu ada tepat
satu, satu dalam setiap lajur dengan semua entri lain sama dengan sifar.
Dan ni dia formulanya. Entri b, a bagi M adalah sama dengan satu kalau b sama dengan f dari a
dan kalau tidak, ia sama dengan sifar, dan dengan ni, kita maksudkan
ini adalah entri M yang barisnya berpadanan dengan b
dan lajurnya berpadanan dengan a.
WEBVTT
Kita akan tengok beberapa contoh sebentar lagi, dan kita akan faham kenapa formula ni berfungsi.
Sekarang, mungkin tak jelas kenapa kita nak ambil fungsi dan nyatakannya sebagai matriks macam ni,
tapi memang masuk akal untuk buat ni. Salah satu sebabnya, dan mungkin, ia sebab utama, adalah kalau kita ada sistem
dalam keadaan kebarangkalian
dan kita lakukan operasi deterministik
pada sistem tu, maka keadaan kebarangkalian yang terhasil boleh diperolehi
dengan pendaraban matriks-vektor, iaitu, kalau sistem kita
berada dalam keadaan kebarangkalian
yang diwakili oleh
beberapa vektor kebarangkalian v dan kita lakukan operasi deterministik yang diterangkan oleh M
pada sistem tu, maka keadaan kebarangkalian yang terhasil akan diberikan oleh M darab v.
Di sini, by the way, anak panah dengan bar kecil padanya macam ni hanyalah notasi biasa dalam matematik untuk menunjukkan macam mana satu
perkara dipetakan ke
atau diubah menjadi perkara lain. Korang boleh je guna anak panah biasa, tapi ini adalah konvensional
dan ia boleh dikenali dan mungkin ia sedikit lebih spesifik daripada sekadar anak panah, yang boleh bermaksud banyak perkara berbeza.
Sekarang jom tengok contoh atau koleksi contoh, sebenarnya.
Jom tengok apa yang berlaku bila kita ambil set keadaan klasik sigma kita sekali lagi sebagai abjad binari.
Tak banyak fungsi berbeza dalam bentuk yang kita bincangkan bila ni adalah set keadaan klasik kita dan lebih tepat lagi, ada hanya empat
fungsi dalam bentuk ni.
Di sini, empat fungsi tu diterangkan oleh jadual nilai yang dipanggil.
Jadual pertama menerangkan
fungsi pertama, yang kita namakan f1.
Untuk setiap input yang mungkin di sebelah kiri, kita senaraikan output yang berpadanan
di sebelah kanan, jadi f1 dari sifar adalah sama dengan sifar,
dan f1 dari satu adalah, sekali lagi, sama dengan sifar, dan itu bermakna f1 adalah
fungsi sifar malar.
Ia sentiasa ambil nilai sifar.
Fungsi kedua f2
adalah fungsi identiti.
Output sentiasa sama dengan input macam yang korang boleh tengok dari jadual kedua.
Fungsi ketiga f3 diterangkan
oleh jadual ketiga.
f3 dari sifar adalah sama dengan satu, dan f3 dari satu adalah sama dengan sifar.
Fungsi ni lebih dikenali
sebagai fungsi not atau negasi logik.
Kita kadang-kadang juga panggil ia bit flip sebab ia terbalikkan sifar
kepada satu dan satu kepada sifar.
Fungsi terakhir f4 adalah,
sekali lagi, fungsi malar sama macam yang pertama, tapi yang ni adalah fungsi satu malar
sebab ia sentiasa ambil nilai satu.
Dan itulah sahaja empat fungsi daripada abjad binari kepada dirinya sendiri.
Ni empat matriks yang berpadanan dengan empat fungsi ni yang diterangkan oleh
formula dari sebelum ni,
yang boleh korang tengok kat sini, dan kalau korang berminat, korang boleh rehat video dan semak ni.
Ingat sahaja bahawa dengan matriks, susunan indeks sentiasa baris dahulu, lajur kedua.
Jadi entri b, a berpadanan
dengan baris b dan lajur a atau baris yang berpadanan
dengan keadaan klasik b
dan lajur yang berpadanan
dengan keadaan klasik a.
Jadi contohnya, kalau kita tengok
fungsi pertama, kita ada f1 dari sifar adalah sama dengan sifar
dan sewajarnya, entri
sifar, sifar M1 adalah sama dengan satu.
Nah, entri satu, sifar
yang ada kat sini adalah sama dengan sifar, dan korang boleh buat perkara yang sama untuk kes
di mana input adalah sama dengan satu dan begitu juga, untuk
tiga fungsi lain.
Korang juga boleh semak bahawa
formula dari sebelum ni adalah benar dan korang boleh pergi satu persatu melalui semua
kemungkinan berbeza untuk sahkan ni.
Dan sebenarnya, kalau korang fikirkan macam mana
pendaraban matriks berfungsi, korang boleh agak je ni.
Bila korang darabkan matriks kepada faktor asas standard macam ni, korang boleh bayangkan korang mengambil input
dan menjatuhkannya ke dalam
bahagian atas salah satu matriks dalam lajur mana yang berpadanan
dengan keadaan klasik
dalam ket tu, dan output yang
korang dapat hanyalah lajur tu sebagai vektor kebarangkalian.
Jadi contohnya, M3 didarab kepada ket
sifar memberikan korang sifar, satu
sebagai vektor kebarangkalian, yang mana adalah ket satu.
M3 didarab kepada ket
satu memberikan korang satu, sifar, yang mana adalah ket sifar dan seterusnya.
Kita akan bincang operasi pada
keadaan kebarangkalian lebih lanjut sebentar lagi, tapi dahulu, jom perkenalkan bahagian kedua notasi Dirac.
Ini akan membantu
untuk bercakap tentang operasi dan memikirkannya sebagai matriks C, dan ia juga akan jadi alat standard
yang akan kita terus guna ke depan. Tetapannya sama macam sebelum ni.
Kita ada set keadaan klasik sigma apa pun yang kita guna dan kita anggap kita ada cara
untuk menyusun keadaan klasik tu.
Kemudian kita tulis benda
yang korang tengok kat sini di mana kali ni bar bersudut ada di sebelah kiri berbanding di sebelah kanan untuk bermakna vektor baris yang ada satu
dalam entri yang
berpadanan dengan a dan sifar untuk semua entri lain yang berpadanan dengan semua
keadaan klasik lain.
Jadi perbezaan antara
benda ni dan ket a adalah ni adalah vektor baris dan
ket a adalah vektor lajur,
WEBVTT
tapi selain tu, vektor-vektor
ditakrifkan dengan cara yang serupa.
Kita baca ni sebagai bra a, saya tak pasti kalau tu patut kelakar, tapi ideanya adalah nama bra dan ket
adalah dua separuh perkataan bracket, dan kita akan ada lebih banyak nak kata
tentang tu sebentar lagi.
Tapi dahulu, jom tengok
contoh yang sangat cepat.
Untuk abjad binari, kita ada bahawa bra sifar adalah
vektor baris kat sini yang sama macam ket a,
kecuali ia adalah vektor baris
bukan vektor lajur dan bra satu adalah vektor kat sini.
Sekarang secara umum, kalau kita darabkan vektor baris
kepada vektor lajur, hanya fikirkan ni sebagai matriks
yang kebetulan ada hanya
satu baris atau hanya satu lajur, maka kita dapat matriks satu kali satu, yang boleh kita fikirkan
sebagai skalar.
Di sini, by the way, korang patut
fikirkan bintang-bintang ni sebagai mewakili nombor sewenang-wenangnya.
Khususnya, kalau kita
darabkan vektor baris bra a kepada vektor lajur ket b,
maka ada dua perkara yang boleh berlaku.
Satu adalah a dan b adalah sama, jadi ia adalah keadaan klasik yang sama, dalam kes tu, yang satu-satu akan selari
dan hasilnya akan sama dengan satu atau mungkin a dan b adalah berbeza,
dan jadi yang satu-satu tak selari dan hasilnya adalah sama dengan sifar.
Cara mudah untuk nyatakan
pemerhatian-pemerhatian ni adalah macam kat sini.
Dan sekadar nak kemas, kita tulis hasil darab ni macam ni dengan hanya satu bar di tengah dan ia bermaksud tepat sama
macam yang kat sini.
Dan sekarang korang boleh tengok macam mana
bra dan ket bersama-sama membentuk bracket, yang juga
dipanggil hasil darab dalam,
dan itu adalah sesuatu
yang sangat penting yang akan kita kembali
dalam pelajaran nombor tiga.
Menggandakan vektor lajur
kepada vektor baris, sebaliknya, memberikan kita matriks macam yang korang boleh tengok kat sini.
Jadi contohnya, kembali sekali lagi
kepada abjad binari, kalau kita darab ket sifar kepada bra sifar,
apa yang kita dapat adalah matriks kat sini, dan kita boleh pergi melalui
kemungkinan lain untuk tengok apa yang berlaku.
Ket sifar darab bra satu memberi
kita matriks kat sini di mana satu tu dah bergerak
ke kedudukan ni.
Ket satu, bra sifar kelihatan macam ni dan ni dia ket satu, bra satu.
Apa yang kita nampak berlaku adalah bahawa ada hanya satu satu dalam matriks yang selainnya semua sifar, dan kedudukan satu tu
ditentukan oleh keadaan klasik
yang kita pilih dalam bra dan ket.
Lebih tepat lagi, dan
ini adalah benar secara umum, untuk mana-mana pilihan set keadaan klasik, matriks yang kita dapat dengan
menggandakan ket a kepada bra b
adalah matriks dengan satu dalam entri a, b dan sifar untuk semua entri lain.
Dan sekarang kita ada kedua-dua
bahagian pertama dan kedua notasi Dirac, kita ada alat yang sangat berguna untuk menghubungkan operasi dengan matriks.
Jadi jom kembali sebentar
kepada operasi deterministik dan ingat bahawa sedikit
lebih awal dalam pelajaran ni,
dinyatakan bahawa untuk setiap fungsi f dalam
bentuk kat sini, kita ada operasi deterministik yang mengubah a kepada f dari a
untuk setiap keadaan klasik a yang mungkin. Dan kita kata bahawa untuk
mana-mana fungsi macam ni, selalu ada
matriks unik M yang bertindak macam ni
pada keadaan asas standard.
Menggunakan notasi Dirac, kita kini boleh nyatakan matriks ni dengan mudah macam yang korang tengok kat sini,
dan kita boleh tengok macam mana kadang-kadang
ia mungkin untuk bekerja dengan matriks sepenuhnya
dalam rangka kerja notasi Dirac
tanpa secara eksplisit menukar
kepada vektor dan matriks, yang bermaksud segi empat tepat yang diisi dengan nombor.
Dalam kes ni, kita boleh semak bahawa
formula yang diperlukan adalah benar dengan menggandakan M kepada ket a.
Kita gantikan
ungkapan kita untuk M macam ni dan kita boleh buang tanda kurung dan snap bersama bra
b dengan ket a macam ni.
Dan itu sebab pendaraban matriks
adalah linear, dalam kes ni, dalam hujah pertama dan ia bersekutu jadi kita boleh buang tanda kurung.
Dan sekarang, mengingat bahawa kita ada a tetap yang kita bincangkan semasa kita menjumlahkan semua
pilihan b yang mungkin,
bracket kat sini
sentiasa akan sama dengan sifar bila b bukan sama dengan a, jadi tak akan ada
sumbangan kepada jumlah,
dan bila b sama dengan a, bracket akan sama dengan satu dan jadi kita akan tinggal dengan
satu sebutan kat sini.
Itulah formula yang kita nak dan jadi kita ada cara yang sangat baik dan mudah untuk nyatakan fungsi sebagai matriks.
Selain operasi deterministik, kita juga ada operasi yang
sendirinya memperkenalkan rawak atau ketidakpastian tentang
keadaan klasik sistem.
Kita guna istilah operasi kebarangkalian untuk bermaksud operasi macam ni, dan untuk tepat, bila kita kata operasi kebarangkalian,
kita maksudkan operasi yang
mungkin memperkenalkan rawak, jadi operasi deterministik sebenarnya adalah kes khas
operasi kebarangkalian
yang kebetulan tak
memperkenalkan sebarang rawak.
Ni contoh mudah di mana
beberapa rawak diperkenalkan.
Ini adalah operasi pada bit tunggal. Cara ia berfungsi adalah kalau keadaan klasik
bit adalah sifar,
maka tak ada yang berlaku. Bit kekal sebagai sifar, tapi kalau keadaan klasik
bit adalah satu, maka operasi tu terbalikkan bit kepada sifar
WEBVTT
dengan kebarangkalian sama dengan 1/2.
Tak ada nama khas
untuk operasi ni, sekurang-kurangnya bukan yang saya tahu.
Ia hanya contoh, tapi korang boleh bayangkan melakukan
operasi ni pada bit.
Sama macam operasi deterministik, operasi kebarangkalian boleh
diwakili oleh matriks dan tindakannya pada keadaan kebarangkalian
diberikan oleh pendaraban matriks-vektor sama macam sebelum ni.
Kali ni, tak semestinya kes bahawa matriks ada tepat satu, satu dalam setiap lajur dan sifar selainnya.
Operasi kebarangkalian
lebih umumnya diwakili oleh matriks stokastik.
Ini adalah matriks yang semua
entri-entrinya adalah nombor nyata tak negatif dan di mana entri-entri dalam
setiap lajur berjumlah satu.
Itu sama dengan kata
bahawa matriks stokastik adalah matriks di mana setiap lajur
membentuk vektor kebarangkalian.
Itu masuk akal bila korang fikirkan tentang
tindakan matriks pada vektor asas standard.
Korang pertimbangkan keadaan klasik
apa pun yang korang mahu dan korang bayangkan menjatuhkan keadaan tu ke dalam bahagian atas matriks dalam lajur mana yang berpadanan
dengan keadaan klasik tu,
dan lajur tu memberitahu korang apa
keadaan kebarangkalian yang keluar sebagai vektor kebarangkalian.
Operasi kebarangkalian
dalam contoh kita, contohnya, diterangkan oleh matriks kat sini.
Kalau kita lakukan operasi ni
pada keadaan klasik sifar, maka keadaan kebarangkalian yang kita dapat diberikan oleh lajur pertama,
yang mana, sekali lagi, adalah keadaan klasik sifar atau sama jadikan, keadaan kebarangkalian di mana sifar berlaku dengan kebarangkalian satu.
Kalau sebaliknya, kita lakukan operasi ni pada keadaan klasik satu, maka kita dengan berkesan hanya rawakkan bit dan sewajarnya, kita dapat
vektor kebarangkalian kat sini
di mana kebarangkalian untuk
setiap keadaan yang mungkin adalah sama dengan 1/2.
Secara umum, kalau kita lakukan operasi ni pada mana-mana keadaan kebarangkalian, maka kesannya pada dasarnya
hanya purata berwajaran antara dua lajur
sebab itulah cara pendaraban matriks-vektor
berfungsi.
Ia linear, jadi kita hanya puratakan dua
hasil yang mungkin sewajarnya.
Bila kita fikirkan operasi kebarangkalian
dengan cara ni, adalah semula jadi untuk fikirkan tentang
ia sebagai berpotensi memperkenalkan atau menyuntik rawak.
Kita boleh baca lajur satu persatu dan kita boleh tengok rawak
yang mereka perkenalkan untuk setiap keadaan klasik yang mungkin.
Korang juga boleh fikirkan tentang
operasi kebarangkalian dengan cara yang sedikit berbeza, iaitu ia adalah pilihan rawak operasi deterministik.
Contohnya, dalam contoh kita, kita boleh fikirkan tentang operasi ni sebagai sama dengan
terbalikkan syiling adil
dan sama ada melakukan
fungsi sifar malar atau fungsi identiti
masing-masing dengan kebarangkalian 1/2,
dan korang boleh tengok itu dicerminkan
kat sini oleh persamaan ni.
Itu sentiasa mungkin untuk
mana-mana operasi kebarangkalian, dan ia agak intuitif.
Kalau korang buat pilihan rawak
sebagai sebahagian daripada proses, korang sentiasa boleh bayangkan membuat pilihan rawak tu terlebih dahulu
dan kemudian kod keras pilihan-pilihan tu
ke dalam beberapa koleksi operasi deterministik.
Kadang-kadang sangat berguna untuk fikirkan tentang operasi kebarangkalian
dengan cara ni, dan kita akan tengok contoh
ni kemudian dalam beberapa pelajaran.
Perkara terakhir yang nak dikata
tentang maklumat klasik untuk pelajaran ni berkaitan menggubung
operasi kebarangkalian, yang hanya bermaksud melakukan
satu selepas satu lagi.
Anggaplah bahawa kita
ada sistem bernama X dan M1 hingga Mn adalah matriks stokastik yang mewakili operasi kebarangkalian
pada X.
Bayangkan pertama sekali kita ada
vektor kebarangkalian v, yang mewakili keadaan kebarangkalian
X pada satu saat, dan kemudian kita mula-mula guna
operasi kebarangkalian pertama pada X, yang diwakili oleh matriks M1, dan kemudian kita guna operasi kebarangkalian kedua,
yang diwakili oleh M2.
Kalau kita buat tu, maka
vektor kebarangkalian yang kita dapat selepas menggunakan hanya operasi
pertama adalah M1 darab v,
dan kemudian bila kita guna
operasi kedua, vektor kebarangkalian yang terhasil adalah M2 didarab kepada vektor apa pun yang kita perolehi
selepas menggunakan M1. Jadi ia kelihatan macam ni.
Sekarang, pendaraban matriks
adalah operasi bersekutu, yang bermaksud tak penting di mana kita letak tanda kurung ni.
Jadi kita sama mudahnya boleh
letak tanda kurung macam ni.
Itu sangat mudah, tapi ia juga menarik sebab ia mendedahkan bahawa kita
boleh fikirkan tentang operasi di mana kita mula-mula guna M1
dan kemudian kita guna M2
sebagai operasi tunggal.
Dengan kata lain, operasi kebarangkalian yang kita dapat dengan menggubung operasi kebarangkalian pertama dan
kedua diwakili oleh hasil darab matriks, M2 darab M1,
dan itu adalah operasi yang sama tanpa mengira keadaan kebarangkalian
apa yang kita mulakan.
Kita tak perlu tahu apa-apa tentang vektor kebarangkalian v untuk fikirkan tentang atau menerangkan
operasi gabungan ni.
Perhatikan bahawa susunan
kat sini adalah M2 di sebelah kiri dan M1 di sebelah kanan, yang sebab matriks
di sebelah kanan, M1,
adalah yang didarab
kepada vektor v, manakala M2 didarab
kepada vektor apa pun yang kita dapat selepas menggandakan dengan M1.
WEBVTT
Jadi kita sentiasa kena ingat bahawa susunannya dalam sesetengah
erti kata terbalik.
Operasi yang dilakukan
pertama adalah yang di sebelah kanan dan operasi yang dilakukan terakhir atau dalam kes ni, kedua,
adalah yang di sebelah kiri.
Kalau kita tak berhenti dengan operasi kedua dan kita gunakan semua ia dalam
urutan mulai dengan yang pertama dan berakhir dengan yang terakhir, iaitu Mn,
maka gubungan semua
operasi ni bersama-sama diberikan oleh hasil darab
yang korang tengok kat sini,
dan korang tengok bahawa susunan
sekali lagi adalah terbalik atas sebab yang tepat sama seperti sebelum ni.
Jadi secara ringkas, gubungan
operasi kebarangkalian diwakili oleh hasil darab
matriks stokastik yang mewakili mereka.
Ingat bahawa ini adalah
susunan matriks dalam hasil darab.
Korang akan sentiasa dapat matriks stokastik dengan mengambil hasil darab
matriks stokastik macam ni, dan kadang-kadang kita nyatakan fakta ni
dengan kata bahawa matriks stokastik
tertutup di bawah pendaraban, dan cara korang
boleh fikirkan tentang ni adalah korang tak boleh keluar daripada
set matriks stokastik
dengan menggandakan mereka sebab set tu tertutup.
Kembali kepada
susunan matriks dalam hasil darab ni, penting untuk ambil perhatian bahawa susunan memang penting.
Pendaraban matriks tak komutatif. Kalau korang tukar susunan
matriks dalam hasil darab, korang mungkin tukar hasilnya,
dan kita tak perlu tengok jauh-jauh daripada operasi deterministik
untuk tengok ni.
Ni contoh mudah tentang
dua matriks stokastik, kedua-duanya mewakili
operasi deterministik di mana susunan tu penting.
M1 mewakili fungsi sifar malar. Dengan andaian, kita bayangkan bahawa dua operasi ni adalah pada bit, sama macam dalam contoh dari sebelum ni.
M2 mewakili operasi not
atau bit flip.
Kalau korang lakukan M1 dahulu
dan kemudian korang lakukan M2, hasilnya adalah matriks kat sini, yang mewakili
fungsi satu malar.
Kalau korang set bit kepada sifar
dan kemudian korang terbalikkannya, ia sama macam je
set bit tu kepada satu.
Sebaliknya, kalau korang lakukan M2 dahulu
dan kemudian korang lakukan M1, ni dia hasilnya kat sini,
dan ni masuk akal sebab kalau korang terbalikkan bit
dan kemudian korang set ia kepada sifar, ia sama macam je
set ia kepada sifar.
Tak penting korang terbalikkannya. Jelas sekali, dua
matriks ni tak sama, dan jadi kita ada
contoh yang sangat mudah yang mendedahkan
bahawa susunan memang penting. Sudah tentu, ni langsung tak mengejutkan.
Kita semua tahu bahawa susunan di mana
operasi dilakukan penting atau sekurang-kurangnya, ia boleh penting.
Contohnya, kalau korang nyalakan
mancis dan kemudian korang tiup padanya, hasilnya sangat berbeza
daripada tiup mancis dahulu
dan kemudian nyalakannya. Pada ketika ni, kita dah bincang banyak
tentang maklumat klasik dan sekarang dah tiba masanya untuk
bincang maklumat kuantum.
Dan apa yang kita akan jumpa adalah bahawa
secara matematik, maklumat kuantum berfungsi
dengan cara yang sangat serupa dengan maklumat klasik
dengan beberapa perbezaan utama.
Perbezaan utama pertama
adalah betul-betul pada permulaan, macam mana kita takrifkan keadaan, dalam kes ni, keadaan kuantum sistem,
dan ada makna di mana pilihan tunggal macam mana
kita takrifkan keadaan kuantum sebahagian besarnya menentukan macam mana
maklumat kuantum berfungsi.
Kita juga akan takrifkan macam mana
pengukuran dan operasi berfungsi, dan dalam pelajaran seterusnya, kita akan bincang macam mana
maklumat kuantum berfungsi bukan sahaja untuk sistem tunggal
tapi untuk berbilang sistem,
tapi benda-benda ni sebenarnya
ikut dengan agak semula jadi bila konsep keadaan kuantum sistem tunggal dalam
pengasingan telah ditubuhkan.
Ni definisinya. Keadaan kuantum sistem diwakili oleh vektor lajur yang indeks-indeksnya diletakkan
dalam hubungan dengan
keadaan klasik sistem tu.
Jadi kita anggap kat sini bahawa
sistem yang kita bincangkan ada beberapa set keadaan klasik, sama macam bila kita bincang
tentang maklumat klasik
dan keadaan kebarangkalian. Entri-entri dalam vektor keadaan kuantum adalah nombor kompleks berbanding kes kebarangkalian
di mana entri-entri adalah nombor nyata tak negatif.
Dan kali ni, hasil tambah nilai mutlak
dikuasakan dua entri-entri mesti sama dengan satu berbanding hasil tambah yang sama dengan satu
seperti yang kita ada dalam kes kebarangkalian.
Nombor kompleks yang muncul
dalam vektor keadaan kuantum kadang-kadang dipanggil amplitud dan mereka memainkan peranan yang
serupa dengan kebarangkalian,
tapi ia bukan kebarangkalian dan ia tak ada
tafsiran yang sama.
Sekarang, saya tak boleh bagi korang sebab yang baik kenapa keadaan kuantum
patut ditakrifkan macam ni selain daripada kata bahawa
ahli fizik telah menemui
bahawa definisi
ni adalah relevan secara fizikal dan ia membolehkan kita menerangkan dan model
sistem mekanik kuantum.
Dengan kata lain, kita pilih definisi ni
sebab ia berfungsi, bukan sebab ada
sebab-sebab tertentu kenapa keadaan kuantum patut
ditakrifkan macam ni.
Berkaitan dengan
matematik konsep keadaan kuantum ni, langkah pertama ke arah memahaminya dan bekerja dengannya adalah
untuk ingat kembali definisi ni
untuk norma Euclidean vektor, yang boleh korang fikirkan secara geometrik sebagai panjang vektor, sama macam korang akan fikirkan tentang panjang
vektor nyata dua dimensi kalau korang lukisnya atas sekeping
kertas sebagai anak panah bermula dari asal dengan cara biasa.
WEBVTT
Khususnya, kalau kita ada
vektor lajur v macam ni, yang kita anggap ada
entri nombor kompleks, alpha satu hingga alpha n,
maka norma Euclidean v ditakrifkan macam yang korang tengok kat sini.
Ini adalah notasi yang kita
guna untuk norma Euclidean dengan meletakkan bar berganda ni di sekeliling vektor yang kita bincangkan.
Dalam kes ni, ia v, dan cara norma Euclidean ditakrifkan adalah ia adalah punca kuasa dua hasil tambah
nilai mutlak dikuasakan dua
entri-entri vektor.
Jadi cara lain untuk takrifkan apa
vektor keadaan kuantum adalah bahawa vektor keadaan kuantum adalah vektor lajur yang ada
entri nombor kompleks
yang norma Euclideannya sama dengan satu, yang bermakna ia adalah vektor unit berkaitan norma Euclidean.
Itu sebab hasil tambah
nilai mutlak dikuasakan dua adalah sama dengan satu jika dan hanya jika norma Euclidean
adalah sama dengan satu.
Punca kuasa dua tak ubah apa-apa bila hasil tambah nilai mutlak
dikuasakan dua adalah sama dengan satu.
Jadi itulah vektor keadaan kuantum. Ia adalah vektor lajur dengan indeks yang berpadanan dengan keadaan
klasik sistem
yang ada entri nombor kompleks dan norma Euclidean sama dengan satu.
Apa yang tu bermaksud atau apa yang tersirat atau macam mana kita patut tafsir konsep
ni adalah perkara lain dan dalam sesetengah erti kata,
kajian maklumat
dan pengiraan kuantum adalah penerokaan apa yang
definisi ni tersirat, sekurang-kurangnya, dari segi
pemprosesan maklumat.
Ini hanyalah titik permulaan.
Sebagai sampingan, biar saya sebutkan bahawa ada
norma-norma lain yang dipanggil selain norma Euclidean dan notasi kat sini dengan bar berganda
di sekeliling vektor tak sentiasa
bermaksud norma Euclidean.
Dalam konteks yang berbeza, notasi ni boleh merujuk
kepada norma yang berbeza.
Contohnya, hasil tambah
nilai mutlak tanpa kuasa dua atau punca kuasa dua adalah norma yang berbeza,
selalu dipanggil norma satu. Ada banyak
norma berbeza, sebenarnya.
Kadang-kadang korang akan nampak
notasi ni digunakan dengan subskrip selepas
set kedua bar yang memberikan maklumat lebih lanjut tentang norma apa yang kita bincangkan.
Dan bila kita buat tu, adalah agak biasa bahawa nombor dua sebagai subskrip
bermaksud norma Euclidean.
Tapi dalam siri ni, bila kita ada
vektor lajur macam ni, notasi bar berganda semata-mata
bermaksud norma Euclidean.
Ni beberapa contoh
vektor keadaan kuantum dan vektor keadaan kuantum tertentu ni adalah vektor keadaan qubit,
yang bermaksud bahawa
keadaan klasik sistem kita adalah sifar dan satu.
Perkataan qubit adalah singkatan untuk quantum bit, yang sebenarnya hanyalah bit
yang boleh berada dalam keadaan kuantum.
Dua contoh pertama sangat mudah. Vektor asas standard
ket sifar dan ket satu adalah vektor keadaan kuantum.
Kedua-duanya adalah vektor lajur, dan indeks-indeks berpadanan
dengan keadaan klasik adalah sifar dan satu, dan entri-entri vektor-vektor ni adalah nombor kompleks.
Untuk vektor-vektor tertentu ni, entri-entrinya adalah sifar dan satu, yang mana adalah nombor nyata, dan sebenarnya, ia adalah integer, tapi ia juga nombor kompleks
yang kebetulan ada
bahagian khayalan sama dengan sifar.
Setiap vektor ada satu entri sama dengan satu dan satu entri sama dengan sifar.
Jadi bila kita jumlahkan nilai mutlak
entri-entri, kita dapat satu dalam kedua-dua kes.
Jadi syarat-syarat
yang diperlukan untuk vektor-vektor ni menjadi vektor keadaan kuantum dipenuhi.
Dua contoh seterusnya adalah keadaan qubit yang sangat biasa dijumpai dipanggil keadaan plus dan keadaan minus.
Ia dinotasikan macam yang
korang tengok kat skrin, sama ada dengan ket plus
atau ket minus macam ni, dan ia ditakrifkan macam yang korang boleh tengok kat sini.
Sekali lagi, entri-entri vektor-vektor
ni adalah nombor kompleks. Kali ni, ia sama ada positif satu lebih punca kuasa dua dua atau negatif satu lebih punca kuasa dua dua,
dan bila kita jumlahkan
nilai mutlak dikuasakan dua, kita dapat 1/2 tambah 1/2, yang mana adalah satu.
By the way, meletakkan
tanda tambah atau tanda tolak dalam ket macam ni
mungkin nampak sedikit pelik sebab ini bukan keadaan klasik
sistem kita,
tapi notasi ni tetap digunakan, dan kita akan kembali ke ni sebentar lagi.
Tapi buat masa ni, secara ringkas, kita boleh guna notasi Dirac untuk letak nama apa pun yang kita nak untuk vektor dalam ket.
Vektor tu tak perlu
menjadi vektor asas standard bila kita guna notasi Dirac.
Ni contoh keadaan qubit terakhir
buat masa ni, pun.
Ia adalah vektor keadaan kuantum qubit yang tak ada nama khas, dan ia tak khusus sangat.
Entri-entri vektor ni adalah satu tambah dua darab i
lebih tiga dan negatif 2/3.
Ini adalah nombor kompleks, dan kalau korang kira nilai
mutlak dikuasakan dua dua entri ni, korang akan dapat 5/9 untuk yang pertama
dan 4/9 untuk yang kedua. Jadi hasil tambah nilai mutlak
dikuasakan dua adalah sama dengan satu.
Dan ni satu contoh terakhir. Kali ni untuk sistem
yang keadaan klasiknya adalah empat suit kad.
Saya tak tahu kenapa kita nak ada sistem yang keadaan klasiknya
adalah empat suit kad yang berada dalam keadaan kuantum, tapi ia mungkin pada prinsipnya
dan ia hanya dimaksudkan sebagai contoh.
WEBVTT
Entri-entri yang berpadanan
dengan suit-suit berbeza adalah 1/2 untuk clubs, negatif
i lebih dua untuk diamonds,
sifar untuk hearts sebab ia tak muncul dalam jumlah dan satu lebih punca
kuasa dua dua untuk spades.
Dan ni macam mana ia kelihatan
sebagai vektor lajur, dengan andaian kita telah susun
keadaan klasik macam yang kita buat sebelum ni,
yang mana adalah susunan
yang korang tengok kat sini.
Mengambil nilai mutlak
dikuasakan dua entri-entri ni memberikan satu suku empat untuk yang pertama, juga satu suku empat untuk yang seterusnya.
Nilai mutlak dikuasakan dua
sifar adalah sama dengan sifar, jadi entri tu tak
menyumbang kepada jumlah.
Dan akhirnya, untuk yang terakhir, kita dapat 1/2. Jadi jumlahnya adalah sama dengan satu macam yang diperlukan untuk vektor ni
menjadi vektor keadaan kuantum.
Sekarang sebentar tadi, kita guna notasi
ket plus dan ket minus untuk merujuk dua vektor keadaan qubit yang bukan vektor asas standard.
Dan saya nak kembali
ke perkara ni sebentar dan terangkan macam mana notasi Dirac digunakan untuk vektor sewenang-wenangnya dan bukan hanya untuk vektor asas standard.
Macam yang saya dah sebutkan, kita boleh guna nama apa pun yang
kita nak dalam bra atau ket untuk merujuk vektor.
Ket adalah vektor lajur
dan bra adalah vektor baris sama macam sebelum ni.
Sebagai contoh, huruf Greek
psi sangat biasa digunakan dalam ket untuk merujuk beberapa vektor sewenang-wenangnya,
dan kat sini, kita menggunakannya untuk
bagi nama kepada vektor keadaan dari sebelum ni yang tak
ada nama khas.
Bila kita buat ni, huruf psi tak
semestinya ada sebarang makna dengan sendirinya.
Ia hanya nama vektor, dan ia dalam ket untuk bantu kita jelaskan
bahawa ia adalah vektor lajur.
Ini boleh jadi sedikit
mengelirukan kadang-kadang, dan ada potensi untuk kesamaran kalau huruf psi boleh dikaitkan
dengan keadaan klasik
sesuatu sistem contohnya, tapi ia umumnya tak
menyebabkan sebarang masalah, dan korang tak perlu guna
notasi Dirac macam ni
kalau korang tak nak. Menggunakan huruf kecil seperti
u, v, atau w tanpa ket juga merupakan cara yang baik untuk
menyatakan vektor lajur
atau lebih khusus lagi,
vektor keadaan kuantum.
Pilihan korang notasi apa
yang korang nak guna untuk nyatakan diri korang.
Korang hanya perlu pastikan
nombor satu, makna apa yang korang
cuba nyatakan adalah jelas kepada orang lain.
Dan nombor dua, korang faham apa yang
orang lain cuba nyatakan walaupun pilihan notasi mereka tak sama dengan korang.
Ada satu peraturan yang sangat penting untuk menggunakan notasi Dirac
untuk vektor sewenang-wenangnya dan itu adalah kalau korang ada vektor lajur
yang korang dah putuskan untuk tulis
sebagai ket psi, contohnya, atau ia boleh jadi nama
berbeza dalam ket, maka vektor baris bra psi
difahami sebagai
konjugat transpose vektor ket psi.
Dan kat sini, ini ditulis sebagai persamaan di mana dagger kat sini merujuk kepada konjugat transpose.
Apa itu khususnya adalah
vektor baris yang korang dapat dengan, nombor satu, mentranspose vektor, bermakna korang terbalikkan vektor tu ke tepinya dan korang ubah ia daripada lajur kepada baris
tanpa betul-betul mengubah entri-entri. Dan nombor dua, mengambil konjugat kompleks
setiap entri.
Korang sebenarnya boleh lakukan
dua operasi tu, transpose dan
konjugat kompleks entri demi entri dalam mana-mana susunan atau kedua-dua operasi tu bertukar.
Jadi untuk vektor dalam contoh ni, memandangkan kita dah putuskan untuk
panggil vektor ni ket psi, difahami bahawa bra psi
bermaksud vektor kat sini
di mana kita dah transpose vektor dengan mengubah ket sifar dan ket
satu kepada bra sifar dan bra satu, dan kita dah ambil konjugat kompleks setiap entri,
itulah sebabnya satu tambah
dua darab i lebih tiga berubah menjadi satu tolak dua
darab i lebih tiga kat sini.
Ni macam mana vektor-vektor ni kelihatan bila ditulis
secara eksplisit sebagai vektor lajur dan vektor baris.
Perhatikan, by the way, bahawa
peraturan ni adalah konsisten dengan notasi yang kita guna bila kita ada keadaan klasik
dalam bra dan ket.
Dalam kes tu, entri-entrinya adalah
semua sifar kecuali satu, satu, dan jadi mengambil
konjugat kompleks tak buat apa-apa dalam kes tu.
Kita kini dah tengok macam mana keadaan kuantum diwakili sebagai vektor, tapi tak jelas pada ketika
ni apa maksud atau implikasinya
dari segi apa yang
boleh korang buat dengan sistem dalam keadaan kuantum atau macam mana korang boleh berinteraksi dengannya.
Perkara pertama yang kita perlu buat untuk bawa isu-isu ni ke fokus
adalah untuk bincang pengukuran.
Secara intuitif,
pengukuran menyediakan mekanisme untuk mengekstrak maklumat klasik
daripada sistem kuantum.
Bila kita tengok sistem
bila ia dalam keadaan kuantum, kita tak nampak keadaan kuantum sama macam kita tak nampak
keadaan kebarangkalian,
kita nampak keadaan klasik, dan konsep pengukuran ni adalah yang menyediakan antaramuka.
Kalau kita, sebagai manusia, nak tahu sesuatu tentang sistem kuantum, kita kena ukurnya, dan dengan berbuat demikian, kita akan mengekstrak maklumat klasik
tentang keadaan kuantum
apa pun sistem tu.
Ada konsep-konsep
pengukuran yang berbeza. Perbezaannya adalah soal keumuman sebenarnya, dan kita akan mulakan dengan yang paling mudah dan asas,
yang biasanya dipanggil
pengukuran asas standard.
WEBVTT
Kita akan umumkan ni
dalam pelajaran-pelajaran seterusnya. Kita akan bincang tentang apa yang dipanggil pengukuran projektif dalam pelajaran tiga, dan kemudian kemudian dalam
unit ketiga siri ni,
kita akan bincang pengukuran umum, yang juga dipanggil ukuran nilai operator positif atau POVM secara ringkas.
Tapi buat masa ni, kita akan hadkan perhatian kita kepada pengukuran asas standard.
Bila pengukuran
dilakukan pada sistem, akan ada beberapa set
hasil pengukuran yang mungkin, yang mana adalah hasil klasik,
dan dalam kes
pengukuran asas standard, hasil-hasil yang mungkin tu adalah
tepat keadaan klasik sistem apa pun yang diukur.
Setiap keadaan klasik tu akan menjadi hasil pengukuran dengan beberapa kebarangkalian, dan kebarangkalian tu adalah nilai mutlak dikuasakan dua
entri yang berpadanan
dengan keadaan klasik tu bagi vektor keadaan kuantum
apa pun yang sistem tu berada dalam sebelum diukur.
Kita tahu bahawa nilai mutlak dikuasakan dua mana-mana nombor kompleks adalah nombor nyata tak negatif, dan kita tahu daripada definisi
vektor keadaan kuantum
bahawa hasil tambah nilai mutlak
dikuasakan dua entri-entri vektor keadaan kuantum adalah sama dengan satu.
Jadi ni masuk akal. Setiap keadaan klasik akan muncul sebagai hasil
pengukuran dengan beberapa kebarangkalian dan kebarangkalian berjumlah satu.
Ni beberapa contoh. Pertama, anggaplah kita ada
qubit dalam keadaan plus.
Kalau kita ukur qubit ni berkaitan pengukuran asas
standard, kita dapat sama ada sifar atau
satu sebagai hasilnya.
Kebarangkalian mendapat sifar adalah nilai mutlak
dikuasakan dua satu lebih punca kuasa dua, yang mana adalah 1/2, dan itu adalah kebarangkalian yang sama untuk mendapat satu.
Jadi kalau korang ukur keadaan plus, korang akan dapat bit rawak seragam.
Kalau sistem berada dalam keadaan minus
bukan keadaan plus, maka mengukur berfungsi dengan
cara yang sama persis.
Kebarangkalian adalah, sekali lagi, 1/2 untuk setiap hasil yang mungkin.
Satu-satunya perbezaan kat sini adalah bahawa tanda tambah berubah menjadi tanda tolak, tapi bila kita ambil nilai
mutlak, tak ada yang berubah.
Kalau kita ukur keadaan qubit ni, kebarangkalian mendapat hasil sifar adalah nilai mutlak dikuasakan dua satu tambah dua darab i
lebih tiga, yang mana adalah 5/9,
dan kebarangkalian mendapat hasil satu adalah nilai mutlak dikuasakan dua
negatif 2/3, yang mana adalah 4/9.
Dan akhirnya, mengukur
keadaan asas standard, ket sifar memberikan hasil
sifar dengan kepastian, dan begitu juga, mengukur keadaan ket satu
menghasilkan hasil satu dengan kepastian. Itu sebab nilai mutlak
dikuasakan dua satu adalah satu.
Serupa dengan yang kita ada dalam
tetapan kebarangkalian. Kita boleh kaitkan keadaan kuantum
ni, ket sifar dalam ket satu, dengan sistem yang berada dalam
keadaan klasik tu,
dan contoh ni adalah konsisten
dengan tafsiran tu.
Sekarang, sama macam yang kita ada dalam
tetapan kebarangkalian, kalau kita ukur sistem bila
ia berada dalam keadaan kuantum,
maka keadaan akan berubah, secara umum, akibat daripada
telah melakukan pengukuran tu.
Khususnya, dan sekali lagi, ini adalah sama seperti yang kita ada
dalam tetapan kebarangkalian.
Kalau kita ukur sistem dan hasil pengukuran
adalah keadaan klasik a, maka keadaan kuantum baru
sistem menjadi ket a.
Jadi untuk keadaan kat sini
contohnya, kita nampak jenis
tingkah laku yang sama yang kita ada dalam tetapan kebarangkalian.
Kalau kita ukur maka dengan kebarangkalian 5/9, kita mendapat hasil sifar, dalam kes tu, keadaan
beralih kepada ket sifar,
dan dengan kebarangkalian
4/9, hasilnya adalah satu, dan keadaan beralih kepada ket satu.
Kadang-kadang fenomena ni dirujuk sebagai keruntuhan
keadaan kuantum, dan ia adalah jenis
perkara yang buat orang
yang mengkaji asas-asas
mekanik kuantum tak boleh tidur malam.
Tapi dari perspektif matematik
semata-mata, ia sebenarnya agak mudah
dan sangat beranalogi dengan apa yang kita ada dalam kes kebarangkalian.
Sumber ketegangan kat sini, dalam sesetengah erti kata, berkaitan sifat asas
keadaan kuantum dan apa yang mereka wakili
dan macam mana mereka berbeza
daripada keadaan kebarangkalian. Tapi pada tahap matematik, ini mungkin adalah apa yang korang jangkakan.
Perhatikan, by the way, bahawa kalau
korang ukur kali kedua, korang akan dapat tepat
hasil yang sama macam yang korang dapat untuk pengukuran pertama.
Jadi ada had tentang berapa banyak
maklumat klasik boleh diekstrak daripada keadaan kuantum, dan kita akan kembali ke perkara ni tak lama lagi
dalam pelajaran lain. Kita dah bincang tentang keadaan kuantum serta pengukuran, khususnya pengukuran asas standard,
yang menyediakan cara untuk
mengekstrak maklumat klasik daripada keadaan kuantum.
Topik yang tinggal untuk
pelajaran ni adalah operasi, khususnya operasi unitary, yang menerangkan macam mana keadaan kuantum sistem
boleh diubah. Secara semula jadi, memandangkan
vektor keadaan kuantum berbeza daripada vektor kebarangkalian, korang akan jangka bahawa set
operasi yang dibenarkan
pada keadaan kuantum adalah berbeza daripada yang kita ada untuk
maklumat klasik, dan memang, itulah yang berlaku.
Sedangkan operasi pada keadaan kebarangkalian diwakili oleh matriks stokastik, operasi pada vektor keadaan kuantum
diwakili oleh matriks unitary.
Ni definisi matriks unitary.
Matriks persegi U yang ada
entri nombor kompleks adalah unitary kalau ia memenuhi persamaan-persamaan
yang korang tengok kat sini.
WEBVTT
Dagger mewakili
konjugat transpose, yang kita dah nampak untuk vektor bila kita bincang tentang notasi Dirac beberapa saat tadi.
Di sini kita melakukan
konjugat transpose pada matriks bukan vektor, tapi ia pada dasarnya sama.
Kita transpose matriks, yang hanya bermakna kita
tukar baris dan lajur, jadi entri JK menjadi entri KJ,
dan juga kita ambil konjugat
kompleks setiap entri.
Juga, notasi kat sini
bermaksud matriks identiti.
Dua persamaan kat sini
sebenarnya adalah setara. Kalau korang ada satu, maka korang
secara automatik ada yang lain.
Kedua-duanya adalah setara dengan
kata bahawa u boleh disonsangkan, dan sonsangannya sama dengan
konjugat transpose.
Itu hanya benar untuk matriks persegi,
by the way. Kalau korang ada matriks yang bukan persegi, maka salah satu daripada dua
persamaan tu mungkin benar,
tapi yang lain tak akan benar.
Tapi kat sini, kita bercakap
tentang matriks persegi.
Jadi ni adalah definisi standard
untuk matriks unitary, dan ia elok sebab ia mudah untuk semak
kalau matriks adalah unitary.
Korang hanya darabkan matriks kepada konjugat transposenya dari kedua-dua sisi, dan korang tengok kalau korang dapat
matriks identiti.
Ada cara setara untuk mencirikan matriks unitary, dan itu adalah bahawa
matriks persegi adalah unitary jika dan hanya jika ia tak pernah
mengubah norma Euclidean
mana-mana vektor bila korang daraban. Matriks N kali N U adalah unitary jika dan hanya jika norma Euclidean U darab v
adalah sama dengan norma Euclidean v untuk setiap vektor lajur n-dimensi v dengan entri nombor kompleks.
Dan oleh itu, kalau v adalah
vektor keadaan kuantum, maka U darab v juga adalah
vektor keadaan kuantum sebab vektor keadaan kuantum
hanyalah vektor yang ada
norma Euclidean sama dengan satu.
Sebenarnya, kita boleh kata sedikit lebih lagi, iaitu bahawa matriks unitary adalah tepat matriks yang sentiasa mengubah vektor keadaan kuantum
kepada vektor keadaan kuantum. Itu adalah situasi yang serupa dengan yang kita ada untuk matriks stokastik
dan vektor kebarangkalian.
Matriks stokastik
adalah tepat matriks yang sentiasa mengubah vektor kebarangkalian kepada vektor kebarangkalian.
Jadi bila kita dah putuskan bahawa operasi patut diwakili oleh matriks, yang sama dengan kata bahawa transformasi bertindak secara linear
pada vektor yang mewakili keadaan, pilihan-pilihan untuk set
operasi yang dibenarkan ikut secara semula jadi, sekurang-kurangnya,
dalam erti kata matematik.
Sekarang jom tengok beberapa contoh operasi unitary qubit.
Kita akan nampak banyak lagi contoh
operasi unitary dalam pelajaran seterusnya, termasuk operasi unitary dan sistem
yang ada lebih daripada dua keadaan klasik. Tapi buat masa ni, kita akan fokus sahaja
pada operasi unitary qubit.
Kita akan nampak
contoh-contoh tertentu ni timbul lagi dan lagi, jadi ia memang berbaloi untuk
kenali operasi-operasi ni.
Koleksi pertama contoh adalah operasi Pauli yang dipanggil.
Ini adalah operasi yang berpadanan dengan matriks Pauli, yang ditunjukkan kat sini.
Ia semua adalah unitary, dan korang boleh semak tu untuk setiap satu mengikut definisi dari sebelum ni.
Matriks-matriks tertentu ni
kebetulan sama dengan konjugat transpose mereka sendiri, yang bermakna ia semua adalah matriks Hermitian.
Jadi menyemak bahawa ia semua
adalah unitary, dalam kes ni, adalah soal mengkuasakan dua setiap satu dan tengok bahawa hasilnya
adalah matriks identiti.
Nama-nama yang korang nampak untuk
matriks-matriks ni adalah agak standard, dan korang juga akan nampak sigma
x, sigma y, dan sigma z dipanggil X, Y, dan Z sahaja.
Tapi sedar, bahawa
huruf besar X, Y, dan Z juga biasa digunakan untuk tujuan lain, bahkan dalam konteks
maklumat kuantum,
tapi ia adalah nama-nama yang sangat biasa
untuk matriks-matriks ni.
Operasi sigma x atau X
juga dipanggil bit flip atau operasi not, yang kita dah nampak
dalam konteks klasik.
Dan operasi sigma z atau Z
juga dipanggil phase flip.
Dan kat sini, korang boleh tengok
tindakan operasi-operasi ni pada faktor asas standard, yang macam mana menjelaskan
asal usul nama-nama ni.
Sudah tentu, masuk akal untuk
merujuk sigma x sebagai bit flip berdasarkan tindakan kat sini.
Ia hanya terbalikkan bit dari
sifar kepada satu atau satu kepada sifar.
Ia juga masuk akal untuk
panggil sigma z sebagai phase flip berdasarkan tindakan kat sini.
Tapi kalau tu tak jelas
pada masa ni, tak apa.
Kita akan jumpa
operasi ni lagi dan lagi dan kepentingan
meletakkan tanda tolak di hadapan vektor asas ket satu
dan bukan ket sifar
dan kenapa tu dipanggil phase flip akan lebih jelas kemudian.
Contoh seterusnya adalah
operasi Hadamard, yang diwakili oleh
matriks kat sini, yang hampir selalu dinamakan H.
Menyemak bahawa H adalah unitary sekali lagi adalah
pengiraan yang mudah, yang kalau saya bergerak ke tepi, korang boleh tengok kat sini.
Serupa dengan matriks Pauli, H adalah konjugat transposenya sendiri.
Jadi kita ada persamaan kat sini, dan bila kita lakukan pendaraban, kita dapat matriks identiti macam yang diperlukan.
WEBVTT
Contoh ketiga adalah
sebenarnya keseluruhan kelas operasi unitary
yang dikenali sebagai operasi fasa.
Ini adalah operasi
yang diwakili oleh mana-mana matriks yang mengambil bentuk
yang korang tengok kat sini di mana theta adalah mana-mana nombor nyata.
Jadi entri kat sini akan
sentiasa menjadi beberapa nombor kompleks pada bulatan unit.
Matriks macam ni sentiasa unitary, yang saya akan tinggalkan kepada korang untuk sahkan.
Kali ni, konjugat transpose tak akan sama dengan matriks asal kecuali nombor kat sini kebetulan
adalah satu atau negatif satu,
dalam kes tu, kita akan dapat
sama ada matriks identiti atau sigma z, yang kita dah
jumpa sebelum ni.
Khususnya, transposisi
tak akan buat apa-apa kepada matriks ni, tapi mengambil konjugat
kompleks setiap entri mengubah entri kat sini
kepada e kepada negatif i theta.
Dua operasi tertentu kat sini adalah contoh-contoh penting
terutamanya operasi fasa.
Untuk yang pertama, kita ambil
theta sebagai pi lebih dua, dan kita dapat matriks kat sini.
Ini biasanya dipanggil
operasi S atau S gate bila kita bercakap tentang circuit, yang tak akan kita bincang dalam pelajaran ni,
tapi itu adalah topik penting
yang akan datang tak lama lagi.
Yang kedua adalah operasi ni. Ia adalah operasi T atau T gate.
Dan untuk yang ni, theta
adalah sama dengan pi lebih empat. Dan jadi bila kita kira eksponen, kita dapat nilai kat sini, yang mana adalah satu tambah i lebih
punca kuasa dua dua.
Ni beberapa contoh cepat untuk tengok beberapa
operasi ni dalam tindakan.
Ni tindakan
operasi Hadamard pada ket sifar dan ket satu.
Kalau kita pergi melalui
pendaraban matriks-vektor, kita nampak bahawa apa yang kita perolehi adalah keadaan plus dan
keadaan minus masing-masing.
Kalau kita lakukan operasi Hadamard pada keadaan plus dan
keadaan minus, sebaliknya, kita kembali ke ket sifar dan ket satu.
Jadi kalau kita kemas sedikit, kita boleh tengok tindakan dengan lebih jelas.
Operasi Hadamard
mengubah ke depan dan belakang antara keadaan sifar dan keadaan plus dan antara keadaan satu
dan keadaan minus.
Berkaitan dua persamaan kat sini, perhatikan bahawa ini memberi kita cara mudah untuk kesan perbezaan antara keadaan plus dan keadaan minus.
Macam yang kita nampak lebih awal dalam pelajaran ni, kalau kita ukur keadaan plus
dan keadaan minus berkaitan pengukuran asas
standard,
kita mendapat bit rawak seragam dalam kedua-dua kes, yang tak bantu kita untuk
kesan perbezaannya.
Tapi kalau kita lakukan operasi Hadamard
dan kemudian kita ukur, kita akan nampak sifar kalau
keadaan asal adalah keadaan plus
dan satu kalau keadaan asal
adalah keadaan minus.
Jadi dua keadaan ini memang berbeza, dan ia boleh dibezakan
dengan sempurna oleh kaedah yang saya baru terangkan,
iaitu dengan mula-mula lakukan
operasi Hadamard dan kemudian ukur.
Kembali kepada contoh
keadaan qubit yang kita nampak sebelum ni yang tak khusus sangat, kita boleh tengok apa yang operasi Hadamard buat kepada keadaan
dengan menukar kepada bentuk
yang korang tengok kat sini dan melakukan pendaraban.
Dan ni hasilnya
yang boleh kita tukar kembali kepada notasi Dirac kalau kita nak,
dan itulah satu cara untuk kira
tindakan-tindakan macam ni.
Ni contoh lain yang menggambarkan korang tak selalu
kena tukar secara eksplisit kepada bentuk matriks vektor.
Korang juga boleh lakukan
pengiraan-pengiraan ni secara terus menggunakan notasi Dirac.
Contoh ni berkaitan operasi T, dan ni dia kat sini
hanya untuk rujukan.
Operasi ni ada tindakan kat sini pada keadaan asas standard.
Dan kalau kita nak kira
tindakan operasi T pada keadaan plus, contohnya, kita boleh mulakan dengan mengembangkan
definisi keadaan plus
dan kemudian guna linear
untuk nyatakan hasilnya macam yang korang tengok kat sini.
Kita kini boleh sahaja masukkan
ungkapan-ungkapan kat sini, buat sikit sahaja
penyederhanaan untuk sebutan kedua, dan kita mendapat hasilnya.
Kalau atas sebab apa pun kita nak guna operasi Hadamard
pada hasilnya, kita boleh buat perkara yang serupa.
Mula-mula, kita gantikan ungkapan untuk T yang bertindak pada keadaan plus dan kita guna linear macam yang kita buat sebelum ni.
Dan sekarang, kalau kita gantikan
ungkapan yang kita dah ada untuk operasi Hadamard
yang bertindak pada ket sifar dan ket satu,
kita dapat ni. Dan sekarang, kita boleh kembangkan
keadaan plus dan keadaan minus untuk dapat ungkapan kat sini,
yang boleh kita ringkaskan hanya dengan menambah, dan ni hasilnya yang terakhir.
Tak ada yang khusus
tentang contoh ni. Ia hanya dimaksudkan untuk
menggambarkan cara alternatif tapi setara untuk mengira tindakan
operasi-operasi ni. Korang boleh guna cara mana yang lebih
mudah dalam situasi yang ada.
Satu perkara terakhir tentang
operasi unitary adalah bahawa gubungan operasi unitary diwakili oleh pendaraban matriks
sama macam dalam tetapan kebarangkalian, iaitu, korang boleh kira tindakan urutan operasi unitary
hanya dengan menggandakan
matriks-matriks bersama. Dan apa yang korang dapat adalah
matriks unitary tunggal yang mewakili tindakan gabungan
WEBVTT
urutan operasi.
Sama macam yang kita ada untuk matriks stokastik, matriks unitary
tertutup di bawah pendaraban, jadi korang akan sentiasa dapat matriks unitary
bila korang menggubungkan operasi unitary.
Korang kena pastikan
korang gandakan matriks dalam susunan yang betul.
Tapi cara ia berfungsi adalah sama macam yang ada untuk
operasi stokastik di mana matriks untuk operasi pertama yang korang lakukan
akan sentiasa muncul di sebelah kanan
hasil darab matriks, dan yang terakhir akan muncul
di sebelah kiri.
Jadi sama macam sebelum ni, susunannya terbalik dalam erti kata korang menggubung dari kanan ke kiri bukan kiri ke kanan.
Ni contoh menarik yang memberikan operasi yang dikenali sebagai operasi punca kuasa dua not.
Anggaplah kita mula-mula
gunakan operasi Hadamard diikuti oleh operasi S, diikuti oleh operasi Hadamard yang lain.
Tindakan gabungan
tiga operasi ni diterangkan oleh hasil darab ni.
Ni operasi Hadamard pertama, ni operasi S, dan ni operasi Hadamard kedua.
Kalau kita lakukan pendaraban matriks, yang tak ditunjukkan kat sini secara eksplisit, tapi korang boleh buat ni
sendiri kalau nak,
hasilnya adalah matriks kat sini. Ia adalah matriks unitary, dan kita boleh semak tu secara langsung
atau kita boleh percaya pada fakta bahawa matriks unitary
tertutup di bawah pendaraban.
Ia mesti unitary sebab tiga matriks ni adalah unitary macam yang kita dah nampak.
Kita tak ada vektor keadaan kuantum
tertentu dalam fikiran kat sini.
Kita boleh bayangkan melakukan
urutan operasi ni pada mana-mana vektor keadaan kuantum, dan matriks ni menerangkan tindakannya.
Sebab kenapa operasi gabungan ni, iaitu yang diterangkan
oleh matriks kat sini dipanggil operasi spirit of not,
adalah bahawa dengan melakukannya
dua kali, kita dapat operasi not, atau dengan kata lain,
operasi sigma x atau X.
Melakukan operasi
dua kali diwakili dengan mengkuasakan dua matriks atau
menggandakannya kepada dirinya sendiri.
Dan kalau korang buat ni, korang akan nampak bahawa hasilnya
adalah matriks Pauli x.
Dan itu agak pelik, dan ia bagi korang petunjuk bahawa korang boleh buat beberapa perkara menarik dengan maklumat kuantum yang korang tak boleh buat dengan
maklumat klasik.
Tak ada operasi klasik, iaitu yang diwakili
oleh matriks stokastik yang memberikan kita operasi not
kalau kita lakukan dua kali.
Jadi ia adalah contoh yang bagus yang mendedahkan bahawa operasi kuantum
berkelakuan sangat berbeza daripada operasi klasik.
Dan itulah untuk pelajaran satu. Dalam pelajaran ni, kita bincang macam mana maklumat kuantum berfungsi untuk sistem tunggal secara berasingan,
dan dalam pelajaran seterusnya, kita akan bincang macam mana
maklumat kuantum berfungsi untuk berbilang sistem.
Terima kasih kerana menonton. Kalau ada soalan, tinggalkan sahaja dalam
bahagian komen di bawah.